on va plus loin avec cet imam directeur
du mensuel afrique magazine don josé
rasoir et avec bruno daroux la rédaction
de france 24 ans raphaël bonsoir bruno
ce n'est pas encore une guerre mondiale
comme l'a évoqué lundi sergueï lavrov le
chef de la diplomatie russe mais c'est
déjà la guerre du gaz qui fait rage ou
plus précisément du rouble a car pour
contraindre ses acheteurs européens à
utiliser sa monnaie moscou est prêt à
leur couper le robinet à gaz réplique
immédiate de bruxelles qui vient la
commission prévient les entreprises
européennes tentaient de régler leurs
achats en devise russe s'expose à des
sanctions écouter
la demande de la partie russe de payer
en rouble est une décision unilatérale
et non conforme au contrat crawling
temps de crise les entreprises ayant
conclu de tels contrats ne doivent pas
accédé aux demandes reçues cela
constituerait une violation des
sanctions et un risque élevé pour les
entreprises
cette fois c'est parti à l'imam on est
dans la guerre du gaz dont elle était
écrite d'avancé
ce qui est un peu surprenant là c'est
qu'ils coupent avant qu'on coupe le ski
quand même est une petite victoire
symbolique côté russe et qui montre à
quel point l'union européenne est quand
même extrêmement dépendante encore et
que le consensus est fragile et puis et
puis on a
autant on pourrais je dirais à la limite
comprendre qu on coupe la pologne qui
est très impliqué mais qu on coupe la
bulgarie qui a pris beaucoup de
précautions pour ne pas livrer des
arbres ça donc bon voilà c'est on s'y
attendait on savait on savait que c'est
que cet homme que cette guerre des
sanctions de part et d'autre allait
s'installer dans la durée et qu'il
faudrait qu'on allait voir jusqu'à quel
point les opinions publiques en
particulier européennes parce que ça on
sait ce qui se passe en europe ce pas ce
qui se passe en russie à qu'elle pourra
combien de temps les opinions publiques
peuvent tenir s'il ya moins de 6 les
factures d'énergie augmente si si à
moins de disponibilité énergétique et ça
donc c'est clair que c'est un des
éléments de la guerre bruno le l'europe
se dit prête à compenser risques on a
les moyens de tenir et ce qu'on est prêt
au bras de fer puisque pour l'instant
c'est vrai que les les deux pays les
plus dépendants finalement en tout cas
coup de par la taille de leur économie
que sont l'allemagne et l'italie sont
épargnés par ces coupures oui pour le
moment ils sont
ils sont épargnés mais ça fait sans
doute partie du message aussi au delà du
cas de la pologne et de la bulgarie que
veut faire passer vladimir poutine dit e
menace insidieuse sur le thème vous
voyez je peux le faire et puis
effectivement comme le les iad il ya
aussi le fait qu'il a quand même réussi
un joli coup vladimir poutine c'est à
dire que on dit que les européens se
préparent mais effectivement c'est
compliqué un peu à peu progressivement à
réduire voire à se passer à réduire leur
dépendance soit se passer du gaz russe
vladimir poutine nuit il a pas il n'a
pas attendu c'est lui qui déclenche les
hostilités en coupant le robinet donc
l'europe prête au bras de fer a n'a pas
le choix d'ailleurs là il ya quelques
instants on a appris que ray lundi une
réunion spéciale de tous les ministres
de l'énergie de l'union européenne ce
qui veut dire d'ailleurs contrairement à
ce que dit refais la femme vers la hyène
que l'europe n'est pas encore quand même
tout à fait prête si demain vladimir
poutine décidé de couper tous les
robinets notamment à destination de
l'allemagne et de l'italie ce pourrait
n'être qu'une étape puisque derrière
vladimir poutine prévient les livraisons
d'armes à l'ukraine expose les pays
fournisseurs à des représailles écoutez
si quelqu'un de l'extérieur
intervient dans les événements qui bout
de craie des menaces stratégie
inacceptable pour nous
il doit savoir que notre réponse sera
immédiate
rapide
nous disposons de tous les instruments
dont on pourrait rêver
voilà ainsi prévu la quarantaine de pays
réunis hier autour des états unis à
ramstein j'anime amont en assurant lundi
que la guerre était gagnable par les
ukrainiens les américains sont ils pas
un peu pousse au crime finalement est-ce
qu'il ne vaut pas contre une issue
négociée au conflit c'est dire que
la guerre est gagnée par les ukrainiens
on voit pas comment elle pourrait être
gagnée c'est assez ya un moment c'est
defferre l'armée russe en ukraine
peut-être les repousser de l'autre côté
de la frontière peut-être ça me semble
extrêmement complexe
et puis un changement de régime pas je
comprends pas très bien pourquoi
les américains poussent poussent aussi
loin la rhétorique parce qu'il ya un
moment
comme on le disait souvent sur ce
plateau serre que la russie ne peut pas
perdre l'ukraine peut gagner entre
guillemets mais la russie ne peut pas
perdre donc il ya forcément à un moment
une ouverture de canal à nouveau avec le
kremlin pour voir sur quelle base on
pourrait ce nom pas s'arrêter mais
stratégiquement s'entendre sachant que
il ya tous les risques possibles de
dérapage les livraisons d'un de part et
d'autre vous l'espèce des choses
bizarres de l'autre lac de l'autre côté
de la frontière en russie à des dépôts
de carburants qui brûle on sait pas très
bien pourquoi
il ya des armements extrêmement
sophistiqué qui arrive en ukraine la
russie menace d'utiliser des armements
extrêmement sophistiqué c'est pas très
claire pour le moment par exemple
s'attaque pas aux convois mais il
s'attaque en ce moment à tous les noeuds
ferroviaires tous les pompes à tout ce
qui peut permettre à ces armes de
rentrer mais ils n'ont pas pris le pas
qui serait stratégiquement c'est assez
impressionnant de taper sur des convois
d'armes qui rentreraient en ukraine on
voit quand même qu'on est dans un espèce
de jeu extrêmement dangereux du chat et
de la souris et encore une fois les
américains on peut comprendre leur
position stratégique mais par rapport
aux européens ils sont pas au front ils
le sont par leur part leurs moyens
financiers ils le sont par l'art moment
qu'ils mettent mais ils sont quand même
à des milliers de kilomètres de cette
histoire alors que l'europe est à
quelques centaines de mètres wark
centaine de kilomètres de date d'un
conflit qui peut nous entraîner donc
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on sent que
souvent les positions européennes pas
tout mais disons la plupart des grands
pays essaye d'avoir une approche
relativement pas jusqu'au-boutistes
parce que si jamais il ya l'ombre d'une
petite porte qui pourrait s'ouvrir au
kremlin je pense qu'on
tenterait de l'utiliser
et on prenait pas aussi excusez moi
avant de laisser la parole à bonnaud on
connaît pas le coût de la guerre en
russie aussi on sait pas très bien il se
passe on parle de 10000 morts 20 mille
morts 30000 morts c'est des chiffres est
astronomique pour un même pour l'âme
vient pour un pays comme la russie on
sait pas quel est le coût des sanctions
c'est pas comment les entreprises
fonctionnent on sait pas comment les
avions volent on s'aimerait comment les
trains se déplace on se bat corps et les
usines tournent alors il ya la
rhétorique poutinienne pour dire tout va
bien on résiste on peut couper le gaz
mais on sait pas ce qui se passe
réellement oui j'ai de l'évoquer d'aider
des sites et notamment des dépôts
d'armes côté russe qui on observe des
départs de feu ces dernières heures la
russie qui accuse un semble-t-il
l'ukraine d'avoir frappé son sol de quoi
justifier l usage bruno d'armes non
conventionnelles éventuellement et
jusqu'à même s'en prendre à un pays
comme la moldavie comme on l'a évoqué
ces dernières 48 heures ouais mais
clairement on est on est rentré dans une
phase depuis une semaine depuis le
l'offensive massive des russes à l'est
dans une phase qui va être dangereuse
dans les prochains jours prochaines
semaines d'ailleurs le ministre russe de
l'ukrainien
la dila il ya une heure bon il ya la
fameuse date aussi du neuf mais qui est
très importante pour vladimir poutine
donc là oui on est le 27 avril jusqu'au
9 mai je pense que à l'est de l'ukraine
effectivement ça va être extrêmement
violent extrêmement meurtriers
visiblement les russes ont changé de
tactique c'est à dire que là ils
avancent plus lentement mais avec une
vraie organisation logistique donc il
progresse quand même peu à peu et il
faut absolument que vladimir poutine en
interne affichent au
début où quelque chose de victorieux
pour cette cérémonie du 9 mai et puis le
côté occidental effectivement les
américains hausse le ton bon en gros ils
sont allés à kiev lloyd austin anthony
blinken ils ont réuni tout le monde à
ramstein en disant bon maintenant c'est
nous les patrons alors effectivement ils
sont plus éloignés mais en fait ils
profitent un peu aussi des hésitations
des européens puis ils ont les moyens de
mettre plus d'argent les européens
effectivement ils sont obligés par la
géographie et la dépendance énergétique
d'être plus prudents après les menaces
de vladimir poutine il ya deux
hypothèses soit il ya une très grande
fébrilité côté russe soit que ledit
lloyd austin l'armée russe est
effectivement très affecté les choses
tournent mal pour les russes donc il
rajoute delà de la rhétorique pour dire
voyez on est là on est là on existe et
en même temps ils ont demandé à
reprendre les négociations il ya deux il
ya deux-trois jours de cadets s'ils ont
un peu contradictoire soit au contraire
ils disent ah les occidentaux là vous
monter la pression vous vous moquez de
nous quelque sorte vous passer la ligne
rouge en fournissant un flux d'armes
ininterrompue et ben moi aussi jose le
ton jusqu'à la troisième guerre mondiale
comme la has it en début de semaine
séguéla vraiment message qu'on se
connaît dans le dans la com stratégique
le le le ils ont parlé d' armes
nucléaires dès le début le premier qui
bouge on nucléarise maintenant la
troisième guerre mondiale
d'abord juste de manière hypothétique
pour qui une troisième guerre mondiale
il faut que tout le monde s'y met or
pour le moment c'est frontalement un
affrontement entre la russie et ce qu'on
appelait l'ouest il faut y revenir à
cette notion qu'on avait un petit peu
oublier les états unis l'europe et le en
gros les pays du g7 et part par le biais
d'un pays qui se trouve au milieu qui et
l'ukraine mais il ya la chine l'inde
l'afrique l'amérique latine enfin même
si ça compte pas militairement quoi que
la chine l'inde ça peut compter on voit
pas une espèce de déflagration mais ça
et puis l'arme atomique c'est toujours
c'est toujours la même histoire c'est à
dire oui on peut utiliser arme atomique
alors la théorisation de l'utilisation
tactique ça a jamais été vraiment on
sait très bien que l'escaladent peut
être très rapide et si à escalade tout
le monde perd
je continue à penser que les russes ne
sont pas suicidaires
de quel côté poutine les pardons oui
voilà pas appuyer semble-t-il peut pas
appuyer tout seul quand même me sont un
peu prudent se trouve à nouveau dans le
sud on entoure en général n'ont pas
l'habitude de le contredire mais enfin
on retrouve à nouveau dans la tête on
cherche en tout cas à entrer dans la
tête du maître du kremlin s'arrimer mais
quand même c'est cette bière et déjà une
demi-défaite camp et
j'imagine fait peur à beaucoup
d'observateurs oui mais le fait qu'ils
en soient là
à ce jour et quand même par rapport à la
guerre opérations spéciales balayé en
quelques jours c'est pour ça qu'on va
pas exclure complètement malheureusement
une dérive à la fois sur lui brille
c'est presque apocalyptique de vladimir
poutine aussi voilà c'est dur à dire on
verra à ce moment là effectivement de
quoi est fait le dip state l état
profond russe justement de quel côté va
pencher la france nombre d'européens à
commencer par kiev ont poussé un ouf de
répit à l' annonce de la réélection des
manuels macron le soulagement pourrait
n'être que de courte durée ainsi d'
aventure les français optait pour une
cohabitation dans deux mois n'est ce pas
un bonne odeur ou oui le soulagement
pour oui la majorité des états de
l'union européenne sauf peut-être
oui ou la pologne quel type de
cohabitation bon c'est que jean luc
mélenchon elle n'a fait des affiches se
voient déjà comme premier ministre
c'est une cohabitation ce serait une
cohabitation soit avec jean luc
mélenchon soit avec marine le pen bon
nous apparaît quand même assez peu
probable au vu de la géographie
électorale actuelle au vu aussi aux vues
au jeu des alliances du scrutin
majoritaire de l'histoire des douze
ennemis d'inscrits pour se présenter au
second tour on va pas rentrer dans les
détails techniques du suffrage
majoritaire à la française ça paraît peu
probable mais pas totalement impossible
notamment si les discussions
qui s'engagent et à droite et à gauche
progresse assez bien à gauche s'était
pas très bien parti salaire de
progresser un peu que les socialistes ça
reste très compliquée avec les
écologistes à droite franchement
décidément marine le pen à la ddt du mal
quand même cela a rassemblé voix il faut
dire que zemmour ne lui a pas lieu pour
faciliter la tâche en tout cas il
présentera pas de candidat contre elle
ni contre un certain nombre de
dirigeants droite comme eric ciotti
n'ont pas je suis quand même assez épaté
par ces gens qui se voit déjà à matignon
sans faire campagne et déjà il se trouve
ça d'une espèce d'arrogance excusez-moi
va faire campagne le seul moyen aussi
mobiliser leur électorat nommé
l'électorat est mobilisé on arrive on se
retrouve avec des gens sur un plateau
qui disent si jamais on ne gagne pas ce
troisième tour on ira à la rue pages au
relax il ya des procédures il ya des
élections et ce à moins d'impact sur
justement moi je pense que le risque je
pense que d'abord d'abord macron devient
le primus inter pares et en europe là ça
bon c'est un peu le un peu le chef de
groupe maintenant il a il parle
élections il récupère ça y récupère sa
place il ya bien pas d'allemagne excusez
moi pour mes amis allemands il n'y a pas
de ya pas de position olaf scholz se
débrouille très bien quoi les deux îles
puis y aura peut-être une chambre
introuvable je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'on les appelait à l'époque la
quatrième république c'est à dire on
peut parfaitement sa chambre bleue ou
jaune au rouge et peu comment ça
s'appelle une chambre avec avec aucune
majorité qui se dégage est à malgré le
système majoritaire avec ces espèces de
trois blocs qui serait un peu là je ne
crois pas que la république en marche va
se dissoudre parce que malgré tout elle
a un président élu et donc elle va pas
de disparaître de la scène on l'a vu sur
les images il est visiblement partie lui
aussi pour un troisième tour avec les
moyens de la de l'it pas les moyens que
lui confient résidents n'ont pas de
l'état la stature que lui confère le
fait d'être un président donc je pense
que tout le monde devrait être un peu
prudent et le risque pour la france et
donc pour l'europe c'est qu'elle soit
ingouvernable ça c'est possible sur
plein de scénarios qui peut imaginer
qu'une cohabitation
le pen macron peut fonctionner ou qui
peut imaginer qu'une cohabitation
mélenchon le mélenchon
macron peut fonctionner c'est juste et
puis après on va les voir sur le banc je
vais quand même rentrer un peu dans les
délibérations parce que dans le bassin
on voit dans chaque circonscription
d'après les experts il y aura assez peu
de triangulaires trois candidats au
second tour donc il y aura beaucoup de
france gall de frontal très souvent
entre la république en marche et soie et
les filles ce rassemblement national
pour madoff beaucoup de cas c'est quand
même la république en marche donc la
répétition du vote utile est du second
tour de la présidentielle ouais qui a
des chances de l'emporter et puis c'est
non c'est dans un certain nombre de
semaines on sait aujourd'hui on vit
aujourd'hui on vit un jour après l'autre
en tout cas on est d'accord que seule
une majorité en faveur d' emmanuel
macron maintiendrait la position de la
france vis-à-vis de ses partenaires
européens et lui remet une situation des
plus inquiétantes pour le en interne que
quand vous voyez dans les sondages que
60% des français et plus même dans
d'autres sondages souhaitent une
cohabitation c'est quand même plus
problématique pour emmanuel macron alors
je serai pas jusqu'à dire que c'est un
président mal élu comme dit jean luc
mélenchon mais enfin de fait il a été
élu avec un peu plus 38% des des
inscrits parce que c'est vrai le vote
était un peu contraint avec ce match
contre le pen bon voilà il ya quand même
et quand même très rapidement je n'aime
pas d'élan comme on l'a entendu ou
est-ce qu'on se trompe est ce que la
mairie ferait d'abord quand on re signer
un bail y'a pas c'est moins excitant un
jeune comme mitterrand erreur était
réélu il y avait beaucoup moins
d'excitation que raymond a oui mais il
ya fait on appel et mitterrandolâtre on
n'entend pas bruno l'atrocité
des quinze-vingts magma chrono lattre
qui seront des bouées coréen mais ils
ont peut-être moins de stature que de la
maison macro comme une finale ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'en politique il faut
être prudent et il reste plusieurs
semaines il y voit là et on va voir ce
qui se passe il ya la guerre il ya dont
vous parlez comme si même avec vous
messieurs merci a dit même d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci bruno daroux rc
on va plus loin c'est terminé on se
retrouve dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans paris nice
[Musique]